[Música]
en directo américa seguimos analizando
todas las aristas de este conflicto y
para ello me acompaña en el estudio más
romeros a la mar bienvenida ya miércoles
mitad de semana y vamos a hablar de las
tensiones entre rusia y la otan que no
son para nada nuevas pero su relación ha
ido cambiando con el pasar de los años
que debemos saber para entender este
conflicto actual al mar porque
recordemos que rusia se vio amenazada
por lo tanto y por ahí también estalló
todo exacto es muy importante que
entendamos cuál es la historia que une y
que separa también estos dos bloques
para saber qué es lo que está sucediendo
hoy en día es por eso que vamos a
empezar remontándonos al origen de la
otan fue en 1949 que se creó esta
alianza y se creó para agrupar a los
países que consideraban la unión
soviética una amenaza en plena guerra
fría y poder ayudarse a defenderse los
unos a los otros empezaron siendo 12
países y luego se fue ampliando en
europa especialmente a finales de los 90
y a partir de los 2000 con los países
que eran antiguos países de la
influencia de la órbita de la unión
soviética
posteriormente los últimos han agregado
han sido albania montenegro y la
república de macedonia del norte pero
cabe preguntarse actualmente en un mundo
después de la guerra fría que tienen en
común estos países no de quien se está
defendiendo que agrupa a estos países y
esos intereses pues según la misma otan
el objetivo es garantizar la seguridad y
la libertad de sus integrantes
mari entonces con toda esta expansión de
la otan que en relaciones ha sostenido
con rusia pues como bien decías han sido
relaciones que han ido variando a lo
largo del tiempo empezó con bastante
bueno en pie hubo inicialmente una buena
relación también porque rusia todavía
estaba debilitada después de la
disolución de la unión soviética y de
hecho es muy importante recordar que en
1997 se firmó un tratado una acta que
iba como a regular de una manera verbal
no es ningún tratado vinculante las dos
potencias las de los dos bloques y
establecía una serie de normas pero a
medida que fue pasando el de tiempo lo
que sucedió fue que este intercambio fue
tomando otros tonos y un gran ejemplo de
esto un punto de inflexión fue un
discurso de putin en febrero de 2017 en
la conferencia de seguridad de múnich
donde putin básicamente lo que hizo fue
criticar de manera abierta y muy clara
la expansión de la otan y la expansión
pues de su seguridad alrededor de europa
dijo que estaba desestabilizando la
confianza mutua y preguntaba también no
porque se estaban porque se estaban
uniendo estos países y a quién iba
dirigida esa expansión una pregunta que
sigue siendo vigente hoy en día por otro
lado hay una parte significativa del
discurso que ven ahora también en sus
pantallas y es que decía que putin
apelaba en el discurso de 2007 que el
uso de la fuerza sólo era legítima bajo
las directrices de la unión de la de la
onu de la de las naciones unidas- algo
que pues deberíamos recordar todos en
este contexto actual y en ese curso por
qué es tan importante para entender lo
que está sucediendo y marc pues porque
al final raúl lo que hace es sentar las
bases de los argumentos que hoy mismo
también está esgrimiendo putin para
invadir ucrania para esta ofensiva
militar no asegurar que la expansión de
la otan en lo que hace es poner en
riesgo la estabilidad europa un gran
ejemplo es lo que sucedió en 2008 en ese
momento la otan fue que dijo que
aseguraba que darían la bienvenida a
georgia y ucrania si estos países
querían entrar a la otan estos ambos
países habían manifestado esa intención
y eso cruzó una línea roja para putin
por qué pues porque como ven en sus
mapas tanto ucrania como georgia son dos
zonas de como unos colchones entre las
fronteras que hay actualmente entre la
otan y la rusa y rusia ven en ese tono
verdoso los países que antes eran de
antigua influencia rusa y que ahora
están bajo el paraguas de la otan y en
cambio también ese telón de acero no es
como todo eso es lo que rusia considera
que ha perdido y todo eso es lo que
considera que eeuu también bajo este
paraguas de la otan se ha ido acercando
a sus fronteras qué significa eso si
rusia por ejemplo si ucrania entrará
alas en la
alianza atlántica eso significaría que
eeuu puede llevar sus tropas hasta la
misma frontera con rusia algo que
también vemos que ya ha sucedido con las
repúblicas bálticas y también por
ejemplo los controvertidos escudos
antimisiles que actualmente están en
rumanía y en polonia y que pues para
para rusia y para putin les hace surgir
esa pregunta no porque ese armamento en
esas fronteras si se considera que no
hay una amenaza militar y además rusia
prácticamente dijo que si ucrania
entraba al otan había una guerra
inminente así es marc que pasó cuando
georgia volviendo a la historia intentó
entrar a la otan pues es que es muy
importante volver a la historia porque
es un antecedente que nos sirve tanto
para entender lo que está ocurriendo hoy
en día en georgia hubo dos regiones que
se declararon independientes después de
la desintegración de la unión soviética
es abjasia y osetia del sur son
repúblicas que son independientes de
facto aunque en principio son todavía
territorio georgiano y que se mantienen
independientes gracias al apoyo militar
ruso cuando en 2008 parecía que georgia
podía entrar a la otan en un futuro
cercano el gobierno georgiano como que
se envalentonó y decidió intentar
recuperar osetia del sur esto tuvo una
respuesta militar rusa tan contundente
que significó que en cinco días se
destrozó prácticamente todo el arsenal
armamentístico
georgia en las armas rusas las tropas
rusas llegaron prácticamente a la
capital y esto es algo muy parecido a lo
que pasó
grant ya nos resuena mucho entonces
también sirve para saber que desde 2008
sabíamos que cualquier amenaza para
rusia se convertía en una respuesta
militar ahora hablemos de los intereses
de la otan de que entre a sus filas
georgia y ucrania mar claro son unos
intereses que de hecho han sido
ampliamente criticados y que es uno de
los argumentos rusos y es que la otan
parece hacer intentar llegar cada vez su
frontera más allá presionando
acercándose a rusia haciendo que su área
de influencia se limite simplemente a
las fronteras nacionales rusas y por
último como para cerrar este espacio
raúl cabe volver a preguntarse no estos
escudos antimisiles contra quién son
contra quién son estas tropas al final
ha habido un comportamiento beligerante
de la otan que no ha tenido tanto en
mente la seguridad de sus ciudadanos
sino simplemente pues tratar de
expandirse en europa mar gracias por
toda la información mañana tenemos otra
arista lo que está sucediendo esta
invasión es de rusia ucrania mañana
saludamos a nuestro segundo